[موسيقى]
قصف عنيف لا يتوقف على قطاع غزه ووزاره
الصحه تعلن استشهاد م شخصا في 25 مجزره
ارتكبها الاحتلال منذ امس في مناطق عده في
القطاع قصف يتزامن مع معارك لا تتوقف حيث
تعلن كتائب القسام استهداف قوه اسرائيليه
خاصه في جحر الديك وسط القطاع واخرى في
خانيونس وتبث الصور عن اما سرايا القدس
فتقول انها استهدفت حشودا عسكريه
اسرائيليه شمالا في حي الزيتون بمدينه غزه
الارتدادات كثيره في الجيش الاسرائيلي حيث
اعلن عن مقتل جنديين وجرح 17 منذ الامس
فقط ثم ياتي اعلان اخر عن اقاله قائد سريه
في الكتيبه 51 في لواء جولاني لما وصف
بتعريض جنود اسرائيليين للخطر في الشجاعيه
اخبار تترك صداها واثرها في اسرائيل في
جلسه
محتدمه واجهها نتنياهو في
الكنيست